you know i told you yesterday about you
know separation you know i mean like
my teens and was the smart thing they
say
like things not been good
i mean you're entitled to
do what you think is best
i don't want it
i'm not gonna lie i feel pathetic
because
essentially i feel like i've been
begging for affection and begging for
attention that i never get
as a woman it makes me feel
pathetic and um you feel pathetic yeah i
feel pathetic you see yeah i don't know
you don't can make nothing better you
mean things worse how do i make it
better oh this is productive i'm glad
we're getting one step closer to a
divorce
what kind of response were you thinking
i'm glad that we're getting a separation
this is gonna really help our
relationship
i don't know anyone who's separated and
gotten back together baby i don't
how is separating gonna help us
is ignoring the problem and drifting
further what do you want for you for me
fighting here every day under the house
they call me lay you fighting for me
that you say something else and continue
fighting
forget about that
okay
i've been treating themselves the same
way since batman republic everything was
the same we are problem was like normal
problem was
since
my real estate classes you know they
started to meet people go out studying
that's when it just started to change
okay
you ignore me
and i guess that's why you want a
separation so you can continue to do
just that yeah
yeah maybe yeah i go up there
yeah
good job
you know how to end the conversation all
the time
you know i need time to know and realize
what i want my life you know if we want
the relationship to work or not
you know you need to find your happiness
on time
maybe
i need to hold my own photo with you
[Music]